after I graduated from Hillsdale College
in 1994 I headed west to Claremont
California to study for my PhD in
political science at the Claremont
Graduate School it was there I met our
next speaker and his lovely wife penny
at the time he was president of the
Claremont Institute which as as you know
he was president of for fifteen years
before coming to Hillsdale he didn't
offer any formal classes back then as he
does now but he did a lot of teaching
informally in his speeches and in our
many conversations and in addition to
learning from him I learned something
about him which is that if you claim to
know something in his presence it makes
you something of a ripe target
especially when you're a young student
like I was as any good teacher does he
he wasn't afraid to tell us when we were
wrong which he did to me at least quite
frequently well if you come and see us
on campus in Hillsdale and we hope you
will and you sit in on one of his
classes or have lunch with him in the
student dining hall what you'll see is
that he hasn't changed to bed if
Hillsdale he teaches courses on various
topics now in the classroom including
the Constitution Aristotle and CS Lewis
and he's the author of several books
including the best-selling Churchill's
trial Winston Churchill and the
salvation of free government his topic
today is conservatism and American
greatness please welcome back to the
podium the 12th president of Hillsdale
College Larry P Arne
[Applause]
thank you good morning
thanks for coming tim is like Doug
Jeffrey he's been a colleague of mine so
long I can't remember what it started
anymore he's all grown up now and has
children kim Strasse was great last
night
I can't fire John Miller but I want to
if you come to visit at Hillsdale
College call my office and find out if
it's a week when I'm in town come such a
week and and the thing is I go eat in
the dining hall everyday and sit with
the students and kick the crap out of
them and you can come with me and help
you'll like it it's fun it's the best
sport on earth okay so I'm gonna talk
about conservatism and American
greatness and what that topic suggests
that the outset is there's a split in
the conservative movement about Donald
Trump and I will talk about that a
little bit at the end but first I'm
gonna do what we academics do define
what the terms are and there are three
in this title that Doug Jeffrey has
ordered me to address conservative
what's that America what's correct that
and what's greatness those are rich
terms it's fun to know what they mean
the word conservative comes from two
Latin words calling Confederation
convocation means with something
together and and keep you know the Latin
word is to keep so conservatism means to
keep things together and if you think
about that for a minute it means it
can't really be a fundamental term it's
not about the being of a thing anything
any group of things could be kept
together and that means those things
would have to already be in being it
doesn't it's not about making anything
those things are already in being so
conservatism is an inclination or a wish
to keep things together and of course it
then depends very much on what the
things are
conservatives and I'm one we have an
inclination to think that things that
have been regarded highly for a long
time or performed well for a long time
have stood a test and it's easier to
tell about those things people always
asking me because I happen to like
Donald Trump do I think he's like
Winston Churchill and you know I always
say well there are some important
differences and Trump represents change
of a kind right and so we conservatives
might well have an inclination against
them I did in the beginning and on the
other hand it doesn't tell you enough to
say that you're conservative because
among the things that are very old are
motherhood and prostitution I I'm for
one of them
and since my wife is sitting in this
room you know which one I mean Nazi
Germany was a political regime
Churchill's Britain was a political
regime turned out couldn't both of them
live you had to pick so you've got that
problem in conservatism American
conservatism starts the thing we call
the conservative movement today of which
I am supposed to be some kind of a
leader that started in the late 40s
early 50s in resistance is something
called progressivism that I'm gonna
define in a minute and the question is
what was it for and that has always been
ambiguous there's more than one strain
of that but let conservative mean for us
right now an inclination to keep some
things together understanding that I
won't have said anything that means very
much unless I define what those things
are
what's greatness what does that mean
can't it mean either large list or
excellence
and excellence is a very rich term and
it is a fundamental work where a synonym
for it would be virtue for a thing to be
you know America is big and it might be
important for it to be big in fact the
people who started it before it was big
thought it was important for it to be
big George Washington named the
Revolutionary War American army the
Continental Army but he didn't know how
big the continent was he didn't know
during his lifetime
no emissary of the government of the
United States made it too specific back
and back until Lewis and Clark in 1878
and he died in seventeen
99 I think Matt Spaulding's here he can
tell us so bigness mattered and you can
see why it would matter for a country
because in a country people have a right
to make a living and I'm gonna talk
about trade in a minute I
Lincoln was a protectionist and
Churchill was a free trader and I love
them both but I'm a Churchill scholar
and I'll say something about that too
and to find some terms there but the key
to the American Revolution is not we're
gonna be a whack in big old country
because they couldn't really be sure
about that and anyway that wasn't the
heart of the matter it was that
excellence part of the word great that
matters and what is it for a thing to be
excellent excellence in a racehorse
they've run really fast in fact I was
talking to our trustee Steve Van Andel
he's a polo player except he just
retired and he was telling me about his
horses he's not gonna play polo much
anymore
but he's gonna keep those horses cuz he
loves them and the reason he loves them
is because they love they love to play
they love to run and the best of them
they really love to run just read
stories or watch the movie about
Secretariat or Seabiscuit you know those
horses they didn't just love to run they
loved to win
made him race horses they were excellent
racehorses
Secretariat probably the best
an oak tree do you know about bonsai
what you do is trim roots and things on
trees and try to make them perfect
miniatures of the real thing the
full-grown thing the Japanese take that
to a high state but of course if you did
that to an oak tree you'd be taking away
some of its essence because those things
are strong and oak a mighty oak tall
leafy grape an excellent oak tree if you
just look at two of them the big strong
well proportioned ones the one you like
it has more about the oak tree in it
then either any acorn or a little oak
tree what about a human being what is it
to be an excellent human being
Shakespeare has mark-anthony say of
Brutus and of course Mark Anthony killed
Brutus but he was very sweet to him
until he did that
he says a a Brutus he was gentle and the
elements so mixed up in him that nature
could stand up and say to all the world
this was a man all the elements of the
man what are they right there a physical
presence they're thinking about George
Washington you know he was a very
impressive man very impressive man on a
horse go watch that movie darkest hour
and see when it's in Churchill who was a
little short guy in fact he was exactly
this height I take comfort in that
whenever out Tim can spark watch him in
motion watch him talk watch him argue
watch him move see him on a battlefield
you know he was very brave like George
Washington very brave warlike men would
see him on a battlefield ago Wow
he had a kind of calmness and deliberate
us about it a kind of perception about
it that made him skillful in the
fighting of war very lethal man
sympathetic beautiful of speech and
speeches the heart of the human being
that's what we do that makes us
different from anybody else and so when
we meet people like that we what we
think is that's a great man and what we
mean is not large we mean that's what a
man is supposed to be you know my wife
is a very fine person
and I know that from decades now falling
short and and that's what a woman should
be and you know she's resilient strong
brave too right we all need that we're
human
what about in a country how would you
know when it's a great one England was a
monarchy during much of its greatest
time in an imperial nation we've never
been that Rome was a Republican than an
empire the Greek city-states they were
awesome places and they were just places
in powerful ways but they would look
like despotisms to us today why in one
of the doctrines when you distinguish
ancient political thought and ancient
policies or police from modern ones is
the modern rule is in a decent country
what the law does not forbid it permits
but in the Soviet Union in modern times
or in Sparta in ancient times but the
law does not permit it forbids you will
spend your life living the life of a
citizen of your state and in the ancient
world because they were smaller and
because it was connected to the gods and
because there was some balance of power
in the best of those cities especially
Sparta that was not tyranny in the
Soviet Union that was just the
appointing of some human beings to drive
and manage or others according to a
utopian goal that actually justified and
granted limitless power there are all
kinds of regimes then just like there
are all kinds of horses and all kinds of
people and just like in people the
difference is between one and another
our greater than the difference between
one horse than another and the reason
for that is because we are volitional
creatures that is to say we have choice
we become agents in our own making and
powerful ways I'm in the college
business right and you've seen there's a
few students here so far they seem to be
all girls maybe we're getting smarter
about that I don't know but but those
two young men just watch them because
that you know that's my favorite age
I work with people like that and what
they are is huge potential and then they
grow a lot and mature a lot while
they're here and they become those
poised and attractive and intelligent
and seeing things that you see out there
right and if they live their lives a
different way they wouldn't get that if
they live their lives as too many do
today crouched over a video screen all
the time playing games it'll stunt them
they won't know as much they won't speak
as well
they won't carry themselves as well and
they have a great deal to do with that
in fact one of the rules that you have
to learn to go into education is you
don't teach them they learn at every
moment that they learn they have to be
devoted to it they have to be fully
involved in it because otherwise it's
just what you know and you're just
babbling on and they don't get any of it
and that's one reason by the way why
it's so important to ask them questions
all the time and equally important to
disagree with what they say even when
you think it's right because the first
of all it's fun probably all right you
just you couldn't believe it right like
I was asking what the good is I'm about
to get to that word because that's the
fundamental word and it's the first and
last question in philosophy
what is the good
wonder what that is and when you ask
them that I always ask it's very easy to
steer the conversation to that because
if you ask them what they're doing and
they tell you and you ask them why you
never have to ask more than a couple
more questions and they'll say in some
foreign nose it's good and although they
know I'm gonna ask that because they put
cartoons about it in the college
newspaper they they're always surprised
when I say it and then they think for a
minute and they you know roll their eyes
and then they repeat Aristotle's
definition of the good which I'll give
you in a minute and and then you know
because they all know that I teach
Aristotle and that that is in fact the
definition of the good and they just
repeat that and then I disagree with it
and they go oh my god you know because
the definition of the good is like the
definition of the good racehorse and
like the definition of the good oak tree
and like the definition of the good
human being and I'll get to this like
the definition of the good nation and
that is each thing being fully and
completely itself
that's why Marc Anthony's quote because
you know as we say around us sometimes
I'll say at the college once than
Churchill was a pretty good statesman
you know Shakespeare was a pretty good
writer in fact maybe the best ever and
when he puts that point just think of
the truths it's in kid that that's
contained in that because the elements
have to be there and they have to be
there in the right arrangement and
proportion and order and then you get
anything fully itself when they say the
good is thing fulfilling its purpose and
being fully fully itself which is
Aristotle's definition I would say good
then what about a murder I didn't know
there they go oh my god
you know and or I say Hitler very
effective ruler very good at being the
kind of fact maybe the best Stalin might
have been better
you know it being the kind of thing it
was well you have to go a whole other
step to get to that because it turns out
that evil is not a thing itself it's the
absence of something evil can only be
understood by what it leaves out if you
look at a broken tree if you look at a
dying tree it's the absence of the
treena's that makes it bad Hitler the
absence of the justice and this is the
larger meaning of greatness right it's
actually like goodness but especially in
a country it would have to conclude some
element of mightiness - I always say it
Hillsdale we're big free-market types
some of you are rustling during the last
speech and I'll give you some comfort in
a minute but but yeah you need to be
strong I always say when you know we
like we have the Hillsdale lots of kids
absorbed the theory of
non-interventionism and their idea is
that we Americans would never have to
fear from anything abroad because we're
here on this continent and who's gonna
threaten us and I always say yeah we'll
keep it that can't be a theory right
because you've ever studied the history
of Belgium you know it's hard duty to be
Belgium I think there are great people
myself right but they just happen to be
located by all those who I can big old
powers especially Germany and Germany
had a treaty not only promising not to
attack Belgium but promising to defend
Belgium if others attacked it and
meanwhile they laid a railway huge with
stops on it and loading places on it
specifically for the purpose of putting
a big ol army into Belgium which they
did twice and and they spent 20 years
building that thing so if you're poor
little Belgium
what are you gonna do right and the
answer is you're gonna hope for Britain
France and the United States to come
help you it's better to be one of them
then you might be able to make it on
your own but that wouldn't be good
enough because the Soviet Union and Nazi
Germany they were huge and mighty
probably the largest modern military
ever built was the Red Army in World War
two and they took three-quarters of the
allied casualties and inflicted about
that many on the Germans and they were
massive but were they good good at
killing Nazis that's the only thing I
know about them that's good is America
great and if so what is its greatness
well that's a little hard to say if you
can just step outside your own country
and think about the others all of the
other great countries are very different
from us my wife's country and beloved of
me England did you ever try to answer
the question when did that start
what about France when did it start
what about Rome what about Greece what
about China you can talk about when
modern China started it started with a
communist revolution but maybe that's a
different China for a reason I'm gonna
say our country is not a place oh it's
always occupied a place and must occupy
place but just think how much the place
has changed you know that continent was
enough when they were laying claim to it
in the revolution now there's no and we
have most of it and and that means that
was in America before we got it all the
answer is it was it's not really a race
because the races lord help us are not
mixed up here in this country
how many of you are mongrels because I
am you know my wife is too kind of
because her father's side is Norman's
you know means she's French and and very
old right they go out they they can
trace her lineage all the way back there
and that means my children's on their
mother's side on their mother's father
said but my wife's mother is a Celt
right and Lord they might even be
Vikings so we're all mongrels right but
what makes us what we are is that that
doesn't matter
and I will tell you since we're not all
a bunch of Dukes and Earls in this room
there's no single fact about America so
important for us is that fact this
crisis that were in right now that Kim
described it very well in which was
which I'm going to close the only hope
that we can overcome the massive force
that has grown up behind this kind of
government it's the power of the
principle that we may not be ruled
except with our consent and it doesn't
matter who we are that's there that's a
right or a truth that the claim is has
applied to every human being in the
history of man and it is the claim of
this nation and we have a birthday it's
not hard to know the name when the
United States of America began it began
four score and seven years ago backward
from the Gettysburg Address to the year
1776 and that in that year the rights of
all were proclaimed to be a purpose of
people and that
the people own the government the reason
once than Churchill loved that document
and he quoted it all the time did you
know he thought it was the purpose of
the British Empire he thought it was the
reason the British Empire had survived
because it had learn from us that it had
to be like that he would give speeches
about that all the time and you know it
was true of the British Empire because
in the second the first and second world
wars Britain's power and the Wars was
was expanded by about 40% by troops from
the Empire and the British Parliament
had no power to conscript any single one
of them see he would say they are kith
and kin across the oceans and they acted
like that something United them
Churchill said the only thing that could
do that was the Declaration of
Independence and secondarily the love of
the Queen everybody loves the Queen I've
learned to love the Queen married to a
woman who loves the Queen so you could
call that the final cause of America and
the final cause of a thing what's the
final cause of an acorn it's to become
that thing that it third you know if you
like trees I happen to like them a lot
then then when you see one fully grown
you say oh yeah that's what it's been
doing all this time to become that and
then it makes you a little sad when you
think of it we have a tremendous maple
tree in front of our house you might
have seen a picture of it it's really
great and it's just perfectly situated
and it is massive and my wife who's a
gardener tells me it's dying cuz it's
you just look up in this she's a
gardener right so she looks up in the
top and sees this little thing that
whole thing it's gonna take a long time
for it to die but the first time she
said that to me do you see what that
means it means that every living thing
ends in decay and I said we have to stop
that
she said we can I said well we might
give up but first we're gonna get the
world's greatest expert to come and tell
us how to save that tree and you know
we've had some men and they say it's
gonna last a long time but it's gonna
die think of that phenomenon it means
that the essence of a thing is really
what tells you what it is because if the
decay of a thing was the definition of a
thing then we would be exactly the same
thing as oak trees but it's when we're
fully ourselves with all the elements
that we are at our excellence and the
Declaration of Independence is beautiful
because it protects that you can be born
you know to the Queen of Sheba and
Thomas Jefferson thought that didn't
give you the right to rule anybody I
think what he wrote to the king of
England George the 3rd who wrote to work
in a gold carriage you know and he
writes in the summary view of the rights
of British North America 1774 and you
can read all these pamphlets we do at
the college many of our Constitution
reader you read them and that lead to
the American Revolution and they and
they get stronger and stronger and
stronger while they go because you know
we get mad we're about to start hurting
people and and and you can tell it's
intense when Thomas Jefferson starts
writing penny writes this thing called
the summary view the rights of British
North America and the end of it right at
the end he s his paragraph and it begins
like this and he's talking understand to
the strongest man in the world
let those flattered who fear it is not
an American art so in other words oh
mighty king I got nothing good to say
about you and I don't need anything you
see that spirit don't tread on me that
beckons every one of us to become fully
human we all get the chance it's what
we're made to
we get to grow and I said before we are
so much responsible for our growth that
we're just not going to come out the
same we don't start with the same
natural advantages and that's an
important point but a more important
point is that we do not make the same
use each one of us of what we've got and
the ones who do make the best use they
become like those two girls I've noticed
walking around here look at him and I
knew them when they were freshmen and
now they're women and they're awesome
you see and we have a right to that and
so the greatness of America is almost
all in that and then you just have to
add one more thing and see I'm talking
about conservatism once you hear that
stated don't you of course want to
conserve that because that's conserving
the thing as it is what it means what it
is always men and it helps that the
thing is old that kind of argument is
much older than the American Revolution
although only fully realized in the
American Revolution for the first time
it helps that it's old but of course the
decisive thing about it and the reason
it's weathered all the storms of time is
because it's true and it carries the
proof of itself in its own terms that's
what it means to be self-evident all you
got to know is just say all it means is
if a thing is a man it's a man and it's
the same as everything else that's a man
but that makes it radically different
from a horse enough to have a purpose
final cause when you want to know what
the final cause of thing you could you
could always find out by asking the
question toward what does it move what
does it love the reason we can save this
country by the way it's because we still
love those things and we get terribly
confused about what they mean but
they're there and we love them and
not that hard to read and that means if
you think about them a great recovery is
possible and I believe bound to happen
in fact maybe underway right now they're
the cause that matters about America
more than any other is the formal cause
that is to say how does it work and the
way the America works is also simple to
know and also traceable to a particular
date the date is September 17 1789
that's right 1776 1787 is when the
Constitution was passed out as a
convention and it was it was ratified
finally in the fall to go into effect in
the fall of 1789 and the Constitution is
about 5000 words and you can read it and
it sets up how the government will
proceed or function and therefore what
it will look like and it's understood if
you read the middle of the neck rights
of Independence when they make the
complaints about the king in the middle
what they're saying there is if you
interfere with the legislature if you
mix up all the powers of government in a
single set of hands if you interrupt the
trial by jury if you interfere with
freedom of the press then that's bad and
that's legitimate grounds for rebellion
and so of course just put that in
positive terms and you've got the
Constitution United States which divides
the powers among three branches and that
the most popular branch is where all of
the important legislation has to stop
which keep it closer to us and yet we
are restrained also by the cont of the
operation of the Constitution because it
takes time to make big changes and we
have to decide more than once to make
them you see so the form is related to
the final cause the thing we love it's
for human beings who are the most Divine
Being
on earth and yet not divine so we must
assemble power but we must restrain its
growth now I made the judgment when the
primary reserve were actually made it
before the primary was over but I
decided not to get involved in the
primary I also I was on the radio a lot
was Hugh Hewitt and we decided to be in
Switzerland I had to call him one night
to remind him because he got out of hand
I'm thinking about all this for years
and then the astonishing thing happened
that I decided Donald Trump might be a
good thing now the issue for me was not
was leased trade and I'll tell you why
about that
what does in Church it was a free trader
in Lincoln was a protectionist and so I
don't think that it's written in the
natural law about that exactly although
people ought to be able to trade where
they want to in general better if you do
it that way and in my little opinion if
you let the government allocate where
resources go all that you do that you're
gonna have more government and that's
the problem these days now should we let
the economy develop to the state where
we can't make a nuclear weapon or an
airplane of course not and here's the
thing about all these trade agreements
that I very much agree with mr. Trump
about and that is if you just go read
NAFTA I mean first of all set aside a
week
what those big trade agreements do is
they make subject to international
agreements massive regulatory
bureaucracies this is specifically the
process by which the European Union
became the sprawling expensive intruding
intrusive and perfectly unaccountable
thing that it has become it grew out of
a bunch of trade agreements and they
just kept adding and adding and adding I
think they may have 80,000 people in
Brussels whose job is to monitor free
trade I wouldn't sign agreements like
that
I like the bilateral ones better and
think there ought to be a lot of them
and I think they ought to be minimal and
I think they ought to empower their
governments against their people and
agreements with one another so I very
much agree with that what about
immigration I think that anyone in
principle is an American but no one has
a right to be that everybody has their
rights his rights their rights but he
has a right to enter any other country
an interesting argument from the
American Revolution and from John Locke
is everybody has a right to leave a
country so the despotism of the Soviet
Union was nowhere more apparent than in
the Berlin Wall the purpose of which was
to keep people in a wall to keep people
out that might be a good idea like right
now for example but then the welfare
state complicates immigration a lot and
you got to look to that but above all if
this final and formal cause defines what
it is to be an American then in
principle you can't be an American
except you're in agreement with those
things the practices and beliefs of free
government are necessary
to free citizenship so we should have
rules that people who come in should
have that like rules about ability to
make a living is a great start
you know the Canadian system which is
more or less copied in the cotton bill
that couldn't pass the Senate ten days
ago in a terrible thing we should have
some immigration laws that filter for
people who would live the way Americans
are supposed to live free self-reliant
and respectful of the rights of others
but then I become to the big thing and
it's really big it's the most important
thing and the reason is it's the most
urgent thing
it's what Kim talked about last night
we have changed both the form and the
final cause of our government it's
extraordinary what has happened the
first power of government is to make the
laws and we don't make the laws in the
same way anymore and it's it's a
grotesque how big the difference is in
the Congress that ended two years ago
here and a half go three hundred laws
passed in two years 150 a year that's
about the average since Hector was a pub
in America but in the last year of the
Obama administration eighty-seven
thousand pages were added to the Federal
Register now think about that in in the
British Parliament I've read you in the
British Parliament I read they actually
passed about fifteen or twenty percent
fewer laws in the Parliament and they
did in 1750 and the thing is it still
works kind of the same way and there's a
process and it takes a long time and
they can't their productivity is not
very good thank God for it so the
Congress right and that means that you
couldn't have the centralized management
of everything in the land if you made
the laws in the old way and so we don't
now they're made by these regulatory
agencies that's a different form of
government it works in a different way
and by the way can you name thirty of
those agencies can you name how many
there are
I look it up once in a while and I it's
somewhere around 150 to 175 lot
rulemaking regulatory agencies all of
which by the way
also enforce the laws they make and hear
disputes adjudicated employees of the
same agency do all three of those things
you see and but when I say 150 to 75
when you look it up you'll find that
there's often disagreements from
authoritative sources sources about how
many there are and often in those
sources there'll be an admission that
they're kind of hard to count that's a
different kind of thing and its purpose
is to manage the society in detail so as
to perfect it but perfectibility is not
one of the attributes of the human being
that's what God would be who appears
three times four times in the
Declaration of Independence and he alone
would hold all the powers of government
in his hand in the Declaration he's the
supreme judge of the world the judge the
judge the maker of the laws of nature
and nature's God the legislator divine
providence the executive branch and the
creator which is like constitution maker
and only he right because we can't be
perfect and the attempt to make us
perfect would have to place powers in
the hands of governors who are also
imperfect beings that's the crisis when
I found out that Donald Trump on January
28 2016 published an article in the Reno
Nevada Gazette called the Bureau of Land
Management and the rule of law and I
came across it somebody sent it to me
maybe Doug and I read it and it's it's
beautiful it actually is a beautiful he
understands the rule of law Madison
writes in the Federalist if the laws be
so voluminous and changeable that people
cannot keep up with them then it doesn't
matter how they're made there's still
not the rule of law well now they're not
made by the right process
anymore and there's so many that you
could never read them and that means
that when they're applied all of the
powers in the hands of the people have
the power to apply them and if you take
that on next thing you know the FBI is
gonna be against you and I think that's
just a partisan thing I think it's
thought to be indecent and backward to
think that we should observe the old
forms and purposes of government I think
that that is understood to be a defiance
against progress and therefore a cruelty
and in any Humanity to all the people
who can benefit from the therapeutic
State and so when I saw that he'd taken
that on I thought wow I'd already come
to think that he might win because he
was so bold and people would say to me
how can you believe anything he says and
I said well remember it's a questionable
thing nobody except he has ever been
elected president United States as his
first significant public service you
think I haven't been skeptical about
that and then you know he does praise
himself an awful lot and he's not as
artful about it as Churchill was like
one time a lady said to Winston
Churchill mr. Churchill we are all worms
and he said yes ma'am
I am a glowworm that's better right and
you know people would say to me you love
what it's in Churchill how how can you
vote for Trump but I said wow I missed
that is Churchill in the race
[Laughter]
so I'll summarize my point just with
this we are in a contest about the
nature of the nation and the nature of
the human being those are inextricably
linked because the nation is founded on
claims about what it is to be a human
being
claims that I argue are true and
beautiful and so if you change that and
you set out to change the human being
you're turning what was a representative
government into an engineering project
and we're in the middle of a vast
conflict about that today and the heart
of it is this regulatory state and I
don't know anymore about the future than
you do
and I don't know John Donald Trump very
well I know I'm a little but I will say
I admire what he's doing and I have hope
for it and especially in this area of
the regulatory state I wish him every
good thing thank you
[Applause]
Thank You president aren't we have some
time for questions we have two students
with microphones please wait for the
microphone raise your hand if you have a
question and we'll we'll bring it over
to you there's the girls
dr. Arnn I you promised some comfort for
those of us who felt some distress at
the prior speaker could you calculate
about that place mr. Kriens a great guy
and what I think is I think that I
believe in limited government right and
so I believe that the purposes of the
government are listed in the declaration
dependence in the Constitution United
States and you would regulate trade only
toward those purposes and one of them is
not deciding what industries prosper
although for national security purposes
you might do quite a lot of that another
thing you might do is what the Chinese
are you know very aggressive
have you noticed and and you know
they're just they think that they're
going to found a trade zone there well
along that goes from the Horn of Africa
up to the east coast of Asia and then
across southern Europe to the
Mediterranean and that they're going to
dominate the world
it looks terribly like Japan's Greater
East Asia co-prosperity sphere and so I
keep an eye on that and if I got the
sense that they were trying to bankrupt
some industry of strategic importance
I'd put a stop to that if I could but I
don't believe in general that like I
don't know what's gonna happen about
manufacturing but it doesn't take nearly
as many people to do it I also think but
so so does that help and and I'll add
one more point because the nation
you know politically talked about
politics for a minute right and if
there's this elite you know we have an
aristocracy now and you know James Comey
is about to teach an ethic
course at some college of it and then
dr. Doug Jeffrey salmon you know I mean
it's alleged on good authority that he
applied for a warrant to survey an
American citizen it was a volunteer to a
political campaign without disclosing
important facts that would undercut the
justification of the warrant I think
that might not be ethical and and so you
know I dug Jeffrey sent me a note and
said glad he's already got a gig cuz we
wouldn't be having him and yeah so but
about the politics of the country right
if you get a region that's laid waste to
you know Michigan those places they're
recovering by the way but politicians
should pay a lot of attention to that
and the economy is not as flexible as it
used to be because you know we're in
debt up to our ears and and we're
regulated at the bazoo and the welfare
state is an impediment to work and so we
should work on those things like a great
thing to do in my opinion would be to
take all the Rust Belt states and turn
them into what the Chinese did right
free enterprise zones you know and and
there's a lot of ideas about inner
cities like there's a way to fix the
schools you know cuz turns out it's not
rocket science
to run a school it's just hard to do and
and if you could get that straightened
out and you could get those schools good
in the inner city and it does cost more
money than the average school to do that
well we discover by experience then you
should focus on that and you should pay
attention to regions and people's in the
country who get hurt by changes in the
economy and you should find a healthy
way to help those be
blessing yes Iran could you comment on
the current convention of states
movement my state of Ohio is it's
currently in the legislature we hope
it's passed several states have already
passed it and I think the extensible
goal would be spending limits and term
limits in Congress do you have any
thoughts on that
ooh I have detailed thoughts on that how
many are for that yeah you're all wrong
so so first of all it is a clear
provision in article 5 of the
Constitution that that can be done and
so of course it's a constitutional thing
to undertake god bless you
here are some reasons why it might not
be the right thing to do one is the
Constitution has been amended what 28
times there are two ways to amend it
that's one of them that's the one that's
never worked second
spending and term limits address
symptoms of the problem not the cause of
the problem you the cause of the problem
isn't what I said we've changed the form
of the government and that's what
liberates it to do all that it does and
a very damaging part of what it does is
what is the cost it imposes on the
society and also the attitude of
nervousness and subservience it imposes
on the side of the society through the
activities of the regulatory state and
those are not addressed there third I
don't think that in this day and age
we're likely to be as good at writing
constitutions as the people who wrote
the great one and so why isn't that the
right thing to do to return to that one
and finally I have chosen to spend my
life learning about that one and seeking
its restoration and so I don't want to
put a huge amount of energy
into an effort to alter it we have time
for just one more question I have the
one sort of question for the previous
speaker which was which I didn't get to
which was what about let's say the
pharmaceutical industry which apparently
is doing just fine and it's not exactly
declining so that's one point against
him but as far as the government I
believe that you know the free societies
have won all of the conflicts of the
past and here we still span all of us
whereas all of these dictatorships and
ideologies that relied on the single
guiding principle that they had but they
thought like Nazi Germany or Soviet
Union are you know down in the dust so I
hope that that would prove to be the
case in the future and I agree with you
that the less government we have the
better of who we would be because a lot
of the failures that we see is because
of the interference of government in
everyday lives of people and in the
industry and the regulation of the
industry okay thank you so I'm feeling
contrary so I'll disagree with that so
first of all it is a fact that free
governments have natural advantages
against despotisms but if you look at
the great Wars very often the body count
is very high and if you look at the
Second World War not clear that we would
have won that without the monstrous
tyranny of the Soviet Union and that
thing lasted for two generations right
so a lot of danger in the world
it'd be right to pay attention to that
the second point is I don't believe
myself that less government is always
better I think you have to have the
right kind so it's actually true just a
fact
that the Constitution United States was
written to make a stronger central
government and the reason they thought
they needed that if you read Madison in
our Constitution Reader vices a
political system states were violating
people's rights
they were debates
their currencies he didn't have to pay
their debts they were voiding mortgages
they were mobs that were taking things
out of stores law and order was breaking
down and so the Constitution was written
to get a strong central government for
national purposes checked by strong
state governments for local purposes and
vice versa and then we to be checked to
so the size of the thing is obviously
way out of scale now and if you went at
it with the machete and hacked away
you'd go a long time before you did any
damage it's anything worth it but it's
also true though that we have to
remember that we need good laws and just
doing what we say is not always the way
to get those and that's why the
Constitution has the checks and balances
in it that it needs and another thing in
those big Wars you know I think in World
War two the federal government got to be
70 percent round numbers of the whole
economy and then tenure Bert Folsom our
faculty member has written a very good
book about this and then 10 years after
the war it was back down to 16 percent
well what were they spending all that
money on we built you know we the Soviet
Army was rolling on trucks we sent to it
and the parts and the designs for their
tanks was were the best tanks kept many
of the parts and all the designs came
from us and so we were a tremendous
engine to overwhelm the Germans and the
Japanese so those are that was a time
when a small government might have cost
us everything so you know if that's so
the point is I agree in general with
what you said and I do think that the
chief engine of prosperity is just
exactly like what I said
is the chief engine of learning and that
is us working and we have a right to do
so
Thanks
[Applause]